just tell me in very brief how do you
define globalization
well I define globalization an is the
integration of markets financial systems
telecommunication systems and
technologies in a way that is shrinking
the world from a size medium to a size
small and enabling each of us as
individuals to reach around the world
farther faster deeper and cheaper than
ever before while at the same time
enabling the world to reach into each of
us farther faster deeper cheaper than
ever before excellent very succinct
definition good now I'll move on to the
interview since Lexus and olive tree was
published in 1999 the world has changed
and how do you see this change has
affected globalization as a phenomenon
well you know the most important effect
on globalization has clearly been 9/11
it's barely been in a huge olive tree
event and that would explain what the
daleks even is a huge assertion of
ethnic or religious identity anger rage
into this globalization system but
because it was targeted on the United
States which after all is the heartbeat
of this system it's it's it's slowed
down the system a little bit
it's interdicted travel a little bit we
see its impact on the airline industry I
won't say it's interdicted trade but it
certainly slowed down commerce its put
sand in the gears of the system not in a
fundamental way but the danger that 9/11
poses is if there's another 9/11 there's
another 9/11 that prompts the United
States to really shrink the apertures
into our country whether it's the
Canadian border our seaports or airports
or our rail lines
that really could have an effect in
slowing down globalization at least for
a while so that's the biggest impact the
biggest change since the book came out
but the other I think important thing to
keep in mind because there are a lot of
misunderstandings about this a lot of
people associated the dot-coms with
globalization and so when the dot-coms
blew up people wrote that globalization
is over now my answer to them is very
simple it's true that they're no longer
are five web sites where you can get a
hundred pounds of dog food delivered to
your house in an hour
but there's one um and that's what's new
that's what you have to keep your eye on
people who say globalization is over to
them and that one is amazon.com or the
one is amazon.com or one other that we
don't know dog food calm or pets calm if
it still exists but um I just use that
as an example but people say
globalization is over I would like to
introduce them to two pretty good-sized
countries once called India and once
called China these are two countries
that have bet their future on a
globalization strategy on educating
empowering their people and designing
their infrastructure trade and
governance policies to succeed in
globalization they are two-fifths of the
planet go tell them the globalization is
over and one of the features you said
the most striking feature of
globalization system as opposed to the
cold war system or integration so do you
see integration aspect is being somewhat
hampered by what has happened since 9/11
there is no question that one just looks
at a place like Yale I don't know this
but I assume it that you have foreign
students that may have come for a
semester gone home and not be able to
come back for spring break
because of visa problems it's a tiny
example but I've had ambassadors around
the world writing me about the problems
they're having with smart bright kids or
professionals who have job opportunities
or study opportunities in the United
States that haven't been able to take
them up as a result of globalization
that's a PEZ reason i have not been able
to take them up as a result of 9/11
and that will slow down globalization if
it's permanent my guess is there will be
technological fixes to all of these
things some of them may not be pretty
because some of them may involve
infringement on civil liberties as we've
known them but there will be fixes over
time we're in the adjustment period now
you know in one of your pieces you wrote
that Ram the use of the guy who blew up
the Walter centers first time he's
desired to blow up the Walter center was
because as you said globalization as
Americanization had gotten in his face
and it had empowered him as an
individual to do something about it
now do you see I'm an academician and
globalization the same thing I think
that it was true to a point and it was
certainly true early on and it's less
and less true every day my even Jew
globalization when one speaks about
culturally not I always ask people
what's the most popular food in the
world is it the Big Mac no no is it
spaghetti no no most popular food in the
world is pizza okay now why is Pizza
such a popular food because every
culture has a flat piece of bread on
which you can stick all kinds of local
ingredients and products so in India you
can get curry pizza and in China you can
get sweet-and-sour pizza and in Mexico
you can get you know chili pizza or
fajita pizza and I'd look at kind of the
internet which is now so much of a
driver of globalization as like a big
pizza that every society basically puts
its own local culture on I don't know
exactly when but it'll be sometime you
know near 2010 where there'll be more
Chinese and Indian Internet users than
there are Americans and that's going to
change the flavor of the internet pizza
so yes initially America was the driver
of the system and dominated in the
cultural sense but I think that will be
less and less true with every passing
day
you also coined this phrase super
empowered angry men who are kind of
challenging globalization in many ways
but these people are product of
globalization themselves but they're
trying to create a different kind of
globalized world is that right
well in some ways they're products of
globalization in that the hijackers of
9/11
some of them booked their seats on
Travelocity calm
they were very adept at communicating
through the internet even in even
sending encoded embedded messages with
steganography as far as we can tell
cellphones were a basic instrument of
Osama bin Laden for passing messages and
instructions they were global men in
many many ways and they have a global
vision um I I call them Islam Oh
Leninists okay because in a in another
life ahead Osama bin Laden or Ayman
Zawahiri of Egypt been students at Yale
they would have been Trotskyites or
Marxist these are people with utopian
visions they want to bring the kingdom
of God on earth but not the kingdom of a
race like the Nazis not a kingdom of a
class like Marxist but a kingdom of a
religion Islam mm-hmm
and one of the things you said about the
need for fundamentals that countries
need to have in order to better
integrate to the globalized world like
good governance rule of law education
and the stuff you've said that cannot be
downloaded which is good the point is
the countries which are Mis unfortunate
to be in a geographically wrong area or
economically not endowed how do you pull
up these countries into the globalized
world well it's it's really good
governance in space what do I mean by
that I mean that the key to
globalization is it's not in the
bandwidth it's not in the wires
it's actually in the good old
fundamentals
you get your governance right and clean
get your oversight regulatory bodies
that look over your banking system and
financial system in decent shape give me
a basic rule of law that is a foreigner
I can invest in your country and feel
that if there is a dispute between me
and a local businessman I can get it
adjudicated without having to bribe the
judge with a goat okay and you get those
basics right and good education system
so I have a pool of educated people to
draw from and you'll do fine you'll do
fine if you're Taiwan think about Taiwan
for a second now this is a barren Rock
in a typhoon Laden sea off the coast of
China with what 20 million people on it
there's a third largest foreign reserves
in the world it doesn't have climate
going for it doesn't have natural
resources going forward all it's got
going for it good fundamentals so you
get your fundamentals right the world
will find you the wires will find you
the bandwidth will find you get them
wrong and nobody will find you or nobody
will stick with you for very long
so really success in globalization it's
all about that good old basic stuff and
that good old basic stuff is open for
any country to acquire how did Hong Kong
succeed succeed with the basics Lord
knows there's no natural resources there
yeah
except the fact that some of the
policies of the Western countries
developed countries especially the
United States like steel tariff farm
subsidy and and also the u.s. attitude
towards the Kyoto Protocol International
Criminal Court all this kind of suggest
us is trying to huge on course at a time
when the US is the cutting edge of
globalization and the u.s. is the major
beneficiary of globalization so how do
you explain this contradiction then
you're far too polite
it's not just a contradiction it's a
shameful contradiction it's wanting it
both ways it's wanting to force open
others people other peoples markets for
what we make and export successfully
while keeping our markets closed to some
of the things they make an export
successfully often food and
textiles for developing countries it's
wrong it's a travesty and it's the great
Achilles heel of the globalization
system someone told me the other day
this may not be accurate but a friend of
mine from India told me that there was a
study done about farm subsidies for the
developed countries and if you took all
those subsidies and put them together
you could fly every cow in the world
around the world first class okay so I
don't know if that's accurate but I bet
the direction is roughly right these are
political questions hopefully we'll
eventually get over them
I'm all for buying off our steel workers
I'm all for buying off our farmers let's
cushion them from the ravages but what
I'm not for is being stupid and when
someone is knocking on my door as a
country and saying we'd like to sell you
steel for less than it costs us to make
it and we slam the door and say no no no
we don't want that that's just stupid
and that's what retards your growth as a
country so we all need to take advantage
of the system but we need to make it
fair and there I believe the third world
the development world has a big and
justifiable complain mmm-hmm and that
complaint of course is being expressed
mostly at the WTO forum yes and do you
have any thoughts as to what should one
do over the intellectual property right
issue in WTO which is becoming a measure
of struggle in global trade I don't know
enough about where the proper compromise
should be there now what I know is this
people want to talk about whether we
globalize whether we should globalized
them I don't have much patience for
because globalization here it's being
driven by technology and it is the way
for the future but people want to talk
about how we globalize how we do it
technologically how we do it legally how
we do it in terms of trade and how we
make it fair that's a discussion I'm
ready to have all day long so I would
have to defer to the experts and where
the right compromise is on issues like
patents and but it's certainly a
discussion that we should be
having mm-hmm and and finally as you
know that to the earlier period of
globalization in the late 19th century
which because I have roughly ended the
beginning of 20th with the tariff walls
rising and immigration barrier rising do
you see this the same feminine
reproducing again now with with the
what's happening in Europe visible
immigrants even in this country about
immigrants from certain countries being
more difficult receive howdy serious
well you know the first euro
globalization was really built around a
fall and transportation costs thanks to
the steamship and the railroad this year
of globalization is built on something
different it's built on a fall in
telecommunications cost and the transfer
of voice and data and information in an
era of service economies I see it be
hampered potentially by the rise of this
terrorist phenomena and how it could put
sand in the gears of the system but
unless you tell me that people are ready
to accept radically lower standards of
living I don't think we will consciously
as governments and societies want to go
back to the the pre globalization era
now it may be that there's going to be a
transition here where we find the
technological ways you know I was just
at the Davos World Economic Forum and
when you go there as a participant they
give you a name tag which you wear
around your neck and it has your picture
and barcode on it and you can go to a
computer and get all your messages and
you can even go to when you go in and
out of the Davos conference center you
press this and it gets you entry and
your picture and your whole bio comes up
well we may be going to that system
certainly if there's another 9/11 we're
all going to be wearing Davos badges
around our neck to get into the airport
to get into the sports stadium to get
into any public place that is alas I
fear where we will go but where we won't
go I believe is backwards to some
prehistoric age in the last several
months developments in Latin America
especially our
in China Brazil and now Peru are leading
people to say maybe Latin America is
going to sign off from globalization do
you see that that is a possibility I
don't see it at all
I see Latin America in afraid in my
golden straitjacket struggling to find a
way to succeed in this system consistent
with its own culture the reason
globalization is going on so
successfully I think is more and more
countries are learning how to globalize
how to how to fit their own culture
society and social needs into the
demands of the global market and the
countries that are doing the best I
think our countries like India which
hasn't opened up its markets fully or
China which has gone slowly into this
but at the same time moved ahead I
always say in globalization system
there's just one road folks there's just
one road when someone comes they say
they've discovered a whole new road to
prosperity
oh I grab my wallet I know I came in
here with fifty dollars I'm leaving with
fifty dollars there's just one road in
it's the road of I believe free markets
or liberal markets liberalized markets
and and and liberalize politics but
there are many speeds 9 there's one
roads and there's many speeds in every
country should go down the road in a way
that's consistent with maintaining its
cultural cohesion its social cohesion
but at the same time its economic
development for some it may be 5 miles
an hour for others it may be 50 but
promise me you just won't do one thing
not go down the road at all if you do
that I promise you you'll you'll bring
nothing but ruin and devastation to your
people
excellent thank you very much thank you
my pleasure